uh joe biden believes that donald trump
should not continue receiving
intelligence briefings and is going to
uh stop them uh joe biden was
interviewed on cbs
evening news on friday nora o'donnell
asked him about this and joe biden said
he should stop getting the intelligence
briefings
you may know you may not you may know
that
former presidents uh receive
intelligence briefings
even thereafter uh even after they're
out of office and it includes
uh classified information but we have a
very
i don't want to say very unique it's
just unique it's a unique situation
in which donald trump continuing to
receive these briefings may actually
pose a national security risk and trump
trump couldn't even be trusted with
classified information as president
of course he can't be trusted with
classified information back
as a private citizen and this is the
first time
that a former president is being cut out
of briefings
and here is joe biden explaining why
should former president trump still
receive intelligence briefings
i think not why not
because of his radical behavior
unrelated to
the insurrection i mean you've called
him an existential threat you've called
him dangerous you've called him reckless
yeah i have and i believe it what's your
worst fear if he continues to get these
intelligence briefings
i'd rather not speculate out loud i just
think that there is no need for him to
have
that intelligence briefing what value is
giving him an intelligent briefing what
impact does he have at all other than
the fact
he might slip and say something joe
biden's absolutely correct
donald trump's intelligence briefings
should have been cut off
on the first day that he was out of
office something nobody is saying but is
relevant
is the question of is trump even getting
them
if he is is he listening if he's
listening
does he remember or understand the
content of them and then what is he
doing with that information
morally donald trump is exactly the type
of person
who would figure out how to monetize or
trade access to that information
if he came up with a way to do it i
don't know that he's actually
clever enough to figure out a way to do
it but trump is a sort of like who's the
highest bidder for what i know type of
guy
why even take a chance democratic
congressman adam schiff
has been talking about this for a while
he said a couple of weeks ago days
before trump left office
trump shouldn't get these briefings and
he makes another great point as to why
he leaves office he should be denied
access
to intelligence briefings would you urge
the biden administration to do that
absolutely there's no circumstance in
which this president should get another
intelligence briefing not now
uh not in the future i don't think he
can be trusted with it now
uh and in the future he certainly can't
be trusted indeed
there were i think any number of
intelligence partners of ours around the
world
uh who probably started withholding
information
from us because they didn't trust the
president uh would would
safeguard that information to protect
their sources and methods
this is a really good point aside from
what trump
will do with the information we know
that during trump's presidency
many of our allies were being more
careful about what they told the united
states
for fear it would get to trump and trump
would spill the beans
if they know trump still gets
intelligence briefings that might
continue
cutting trump off from the intelligence
briefings
not only is the right decision from a
national security standpoint
it probably helps revive some of our
relationships
including as far as intelligence sharing
is concerned with other countries that's
something that
is a big task for joe biden
re-establishing some of those
damaged relationships joe biden is right
to do this and
the official announcement about it
happening should be coming any moment
now
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol
wipes no touch infrared thermometers and
all of their prices
are very reasonable i also love snh
masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david